all black people aren't going to be the
same COO and I agree with you and that's
why I'm gonna disagree Carlo I don't
need that kind of foolishness around
[Music]
right over here I thoroughly enjoy fried
I love it you know I understand the
stereotypes about it and all that kind
of stuff but I I love it I just don't
really like fried food I'm not really a
fan of chicken
I've never ate it so yeah you've never
had fried chicken I have had it I don't
I don't enjoy it I don't really eat
fried foods I try to eat pretty healthy
stuff
[Music]
three-two-one
I'm always on the wrong side would you
guys be offended if I had dreads since
I'm biracial since I'm half black and
half white so where is the line like if
someone's a quarter black I'm not gonna
sit there and come to your face and be
like you're not a hundred percent black
therefore you can't like that's not my
place however if you are a white person
and you have dreads in your hair it's
like what what what does that mean to
you and you're not even wearing them
right like you need a wash up I just
don't see how a race can own a hairstyle
to be honest like hairs hair there's all
kinds of hairstyles in Africa I still
don't think that like a single race
group can say this one hair style nobody
else can do it but me
this cookout needs to just die like no
more cookouts no bra just go home like
there ain't no cookout I'm sorry I
strongly agree because I I don't like
the idea of perpetuating this concept
that all black people have to be the
same and think the same and act the same
I don't think he's fully understood
people like Kanye are creatives and he
uses like creative speech and some
people just take him at face value or
like like kind of like the literal sense
of what he's saying and if you did that
every creative could be taken the wrong
way
I disagree that like I don't think that
he's so creative and that his words are
being misinterpreted like he's making
very specific phrases like black people
chose to be slaves that's completely
untrue and in my opinion that's just
unacceptable
I think that's and that's people
misunderstanding what he said I don't
think how do you interpret that no I
think what he's saying is there's a
there's a mindset where we're you know
we're like here so okay like he was
trying to say it in the term of like you
know it was a choice for you to stay
there when you knew that you could have
done whatever else to get out and maybe
would have ended up dead but it would
have been better than being a safe so
this negates knowing this negates the
millions of people who did don't you
believe that today there are people
whose mindset their corporate slaves or
there or there you gotta be careful with
the language you use Kanye's an artist
he's a lyricist so you can't say stuff
like that
they're history yet and some people
don't know that it was millions and
millions and millions of blacks who
fought oppression who fall asleep but
you're right in that he needs to be more
conscious of his word choice because
there's not everybody who's gonna
understand that and that's why I say
yeah somebody as smart as Kanye I think
he's doing this for shock value and for
money and if he's doing that he's
setting people back and that's why I
can't rock with him on it what scares me
is the second somebody Beek in PC or not
or they or they're able to articulate
what they're trying to say well or not
that they're excluded from cookouts and
from from a culture from from your
identity and I think that's scary
because I'll tell you right now the more
we treat people who are different and
isolate ourselves even I think the worst
of this for us long term and to be
honest we're going to drive more more
people to have closeted feelings and
emotions and this goes back to people
saying like like would you rather have a
racist next to you that's hiding it or
would you rather have a racist next to
you that's letting you know how they
feel and you know where they're coming
from who and I agree with you and that's
why I put that's why I'm in a disagree
column he can come eventually once we
have some conversations but right now I
don't need that kind of foolishness
around the children
[Music]
I said strongly agree it was created to
monitor the minority in the group back
in the day it was Irish it was galleons
and so it's ingrained into the system of
policing and that's the problem I think
we have to reframe what policing is now
and until we do that it will always be
targeting people of color because that's
what it was created to do I see it as
like there's a little bit of a
socio-economic piece to it it's like
kind of saying the sec mostly prosecutes
white people through like years of
institution racism you know where
there's poverty and there's communities
that are kind of like have created this
like a perfect storm of
issues like whether it's legal issues
people robbing each other selling drugs
or whatnot you know the idea is if you
police that neighborhood more you're
gonna have more of them arrested can I
ask you the can I be like do you feel
like there are equal amount of rests
happening on Wall Street than there are
happening in the hood like the white
collar like crimes are I do think
they're less like monitored unless you
know but without having all the data
that I need but I do feel that that they
don't suffer as much consequence they
dominate when they commit crime they're
true you got to look at the prison
industrial complex here too in the u.s.
that's huge business so and if you look
at a group of citizens that have been
perceived as no value having to society
or whatever okay boom we're gonna push
them we're gonna pipeline them into that
system yeah I also think that you know
the qualifications to become a police
officer are so low and it's like my life
is literally in your hands man like if I
get pulled over maybe that will be the
day that I go home to be with the Lord
and I think that that's really tough for
me because you don't want to be
distrustful of the police but they're so
incredibly distrustful of us that it's
like you could literally kill me my
father what worked in law enforcement
and he's a black man so there are some
law enforcement officers that don't feel
that way however I think a lot of it
does have to do with fear and the fear
of black people so I think that if we
kind of address that fear level and that
didn't portray black people especially
black men is you know big scary guys
that that would change a lot of stuff
boom walk-in which one I agree that I
act differently around people that
aren't black just because like Corporate
America doesn't want to hear me talking
doesn't hear me speaking in slang and I
am NOT happy about it like I wish that
it was different but I feel like I need
to do to fit into that group I strongly
disagree I am me wherever I go I'm a
proud black man and I'm gonna speak my
truth every day of the week if you don't
like it ain't on me that's on you
and I feel like it's a disservice to
anyone I'm around them from not being my
authentic self because my white friends
might want to think about me because
they want some flavor so if I go in
being something totally different those
different things one thing is are you
changing yourself are you changing how
you're communicating who you are and I'm
changing I'm communicating Who I am and
I still remain the same like do you have
a white voice do I have a white horse
I know I know Cole I'm a black man trust
me every every black person growing up
in America can code-switch here's the
thing the question was do I act
different when I'm in different
surroundings and no but see how would I
ever be accepted if I'm always cold
switch it that means I'm always
acquiescence to something else you see
what I'm saying so in order to be
accepting you gotta bring you do you
guys wouldn't you say coats which do you
mean you change the actual words you say
or do you mean you change the tone of
your voice I change how I say it and I
change what I say I will walk into a
business meeting different than how I
walk in to the basketball court so
that's me changing to fit decision
scenario to benefit the end goal and I
don't view that as a negative I view
that as me focusing on what the end goal
is but I feel like society has made
American Society has made black people
operate in that fashion because nobody
asks is white people too cold switch
they can Britt they can be white in
America China wherever they accept they
wear around like visas but I'm the only
one that has to go around and say oh hi
how you doing
well not right yeah I'm glad that we all
strapped yeah yeah I love that you know
we can have these discussions and like
still go home knowing that we're family
and I and I love I love being black I
love that blackness has expressed many
different ways it's not just one way I'm
proud to be very shy and proud of my
immigrant past proud of my black half my
ancestors brought their own freedom from
slavery yeah I love being black I
wouldn't have it any other way I mean
yeah it presents its challenges but I
couldn't fathom being something else so
I am very proud to be an
african-american community
[Applause]
these habits alone